the bitcoin realized cap has hit an
all-time high now when most people think
of bitcoin they think of the price of
one bitcoin today it trades around 55
000
and somebody may say to you the bitcoin
asset is a trillion dollars and when
they're talking about a trillion dollar
asset what they're talking about is the
market cap itself now the way that the
market cap is calculated is you simply
take all of the bitcoin that is in the
circulating supply and you multiply it
by the price of one bitcoin so let's say
uh that there was 18.9 million bitcoin
in circulation times 55 000 price point
that gets you the market cap so
outstanding number of bitcoin in
circulation times the actual price of
one bitcoin gets you that market cap but
sometimes that's not necessarily the
best metric to actually understand what
the value of bitcoin is so there's
something called the realize cap
the bitcoin realized cap is looking at
the last time that that bitcoin actually
traded hands so let's say for example
that somebody bought one bitcoin at
thirty thousand dollars rather than that
one bitcoin counting as fifty five
thousand dollars towards the market cap
that one bitcoin simply would count as
thirty thousand dollars towards the
realized cap the last time that a it was
traded hands was at a certain price
point if somebody buys a bitcoin today
it will count as the realized cap is
fifty five thousand dollars so wherever
the last time that that bitcoin actually
changed hands that is the amount that
counts towards that realized cap and so
what this does is basically shows the
realized amount of the bitcoin well that
has hit an all-time high as well so not
only do we have the market cap crossing
over one trillion dollars but we now
have the realized market capitalization
breaking 400 billion dollars so even
though tons of people have bought
bitcoin over the years and held it we
know that 85 of all bitcoin in
circulation right now hasn't changed
hands in the last 90 days we still hit
an all-time high in the realized market
capitalization and so the realized
market capitalization will always be
lower than the actual market cap but
it's a really important metric to
understand this specific chart that
we're going to show you now is the
realized market analysis this comes from
a bitcoin magazine article dylan leclair
a couple other folks put this together
and i love this chart because what it
shows is green yellow and red green
shows that there's an uptrend and we're
in a bull market the yellow is showing
some sort of plateau a consolidation uh
really the accumulation phase right
before a massive bull run and then red
is the downtrend or the bear markets and
seeing go all the way back there to 2011
or so you can see that we started in the
green we go massive bull market we go
bare then we go sideways accumulation
mini bull run more accumulation second
leg to the bull run then in 2015 or so
bear market really long bear market
almost two years year and a half two
years we then go into the accumulation
phase right before 2016 bam 2017 hits
bull run go back into the bear market in
uh 2018 2018 to 2019 pretty much all
bear market bottom out around 3 000
but then in the beginning of 2019 we
basically start to go sideways again the
cycle restarts and so in 2019 to 2020
all accumulation we then get that bull
run at the end of 2020 that most of you
are here to experience go all the way up
to 64 000. we then go back into a little
bit of a
bear market there go all the way down to
30k about 50 draw down or so but then we
go back into accumulation so once we go
back into accumulation we continue to
consolidate sideways and with history
repeats every single time you have that
accumulation the next thing that follows
is another move upwards and so we've
never had an accumulation phase followed
by a bear market it's always
accumulation
bull market and then we go into a bear
and so it's important to kind of
understand how history has played out
again it's not a predictor of the future
but if you look at this you can start to
understand some of the market cycles you
can start to understand how some of the
price movements actually occur and what
you can really understand from this
realized price analysis is that we are
in that consolidation phase right now so
pretty bullish if you were to look over
the next couple of months
then lastly we have uh this realized
price market analysis it's just simply a
little bit zoomed in on that specific uh
time period so if you go back to kind of
beginning of 2020 you can see right
there that accumulation phase and then
with the great coloring you can just see
bam into that bull market uh starting in
kind of october of 2020 goes from about
10 11 000 all the way up to 64 000
uh ultimately peaks out at 64. and we
kind of go into that uh that bear market
now that bear market phase what's really
interesting about that is if you were to
look at the market cap
you would actually see a very
significant drawdown if you were to look
at the price per one bitcoin the us
dollar exchange value we went from 64
000 down to 30 thousand dollars 28
thousand dollars but when you look at
the realized price what you can tell is
that there actually wasn't that level of
volatility the reason why this is much
smoother is because most people were not
actually selling on the way down so that
realized price doesn't move for those
that aren't selling the only time that
the realized price moves is when bitcoin
is actually trading hands and so now you
can tell that even though there was a
slight downtrend not quite as severe as
the price or the market cap there was
still a slight uh downturn we then go
right back and the realized price starts
to rise again and that's ultimately
leading us today to reach that all-time
high and that realized price on a per
bitcoin basis just over 21 000 so pretty
cool to see uh the actual data when you
start to unpack it not only saying that
the uh us dollar exchange price kind of
bitcoin equals uh one bitcoin equals 55
000 is bullish not only looking at
things like the market cap crossing over
a trillion dollars that's bullish not
only looking at all of the social
signals or the regulatory regime in
terms of focusing they're not going to
ban it that's bullish also looking at
the on-chain metrics looking at who's
buying and who's selling that's bullish
long-term holders saying 85 of all
bitcoin hasn't moved in the last 90 days
that's bullish and then when you look at
the realized market price as well you
can see that that is bullish
additionally and so when we start to
look at this uh part of what's so
beautiful about bitcoin is that you
really couldn't do this type of analysis
with a traditional security it would be
almost impossible for you to know every
single asset that traded hands at what
price and be able to to uh kind of keep
track and understand what a realized
price was with this level of accuracy